thank you
[Applause]
but Excellence Madame dandelion
issue
Missouri
it's a day marked by firsts first of His
official visit by President Bender lion
to Canada
her excellency's first address to
Canada's parliament and on the eve of
international women's day
an address by the first woman president
of the European Commission
and as Speaker of the House of Commons
I've had the great honor Madam president
to be among the first to welcome you to
Canadian Canada's parliament
prime minister
Michelle president
it's my honor to welcome the president
of the European commission Ursula
Thunder lion to address our Parliament
almost a year ago I addressed the
European Parliament in Brussels
it is our profound privilege to host you
here at the seat of our government in
Ottawa tonight
it is a testament to how deep and strong
the bonds between Canada and Europe have
become
um
[Music]
foreign
Wonderland
you are here as an inspirational leader
who has been Central to galvanizing
support for Ukraine and its people not
only across Europe but around the world
you are a defender of democracy of
freedom and of peace
you are dedicated to helping the most
vulnerable you embody the values that we
cherish as Canadians and our government
and all Canadians are proud to call you
a friend
as the speaker pointed out tomorrow is
international women's day
it Bears pointing out that president
fundalian is only the sixth woman to
address Canadian Parliament like this
and the first woman elected to be
president of the European Commission
she is one of many many women around the
world who have become the face of
resistance to autocracy
women like Belarusian opposition leader
chatlana sikanowskaya who just yesterday
was sentenced to in Exile to 15 years in
prison
or the women of Iran from school girls
to grandmothers who took to the streets
demanding to live their lives free of
persecution and started a movement that
has resonated around the world with the
rallying Cry of Zan zendegi Azadi women
life liberty
and with women around the world facing
threats to the right to choose it is
more important than ever that their
voices ring loudly from every corner of
society
because when women have strong voices
and hold positions of leadership it
makes our democracies stronger
the world is facing challenges and we
need strong
principled and responsible leadership
from people of all backgrounds
so thank you Ursula
for not just being a strong example of
that leadership
but also for putting forward policies
decisions and solutions that are
empowering important voices across
Europe and around the world
is
foreign
ratified
Commerce Canada is
the partnership between Canada and the
EU is stronger than ever it is built on
our shared belief in gender equality in
human rights in international law in a
strong and growing middle class and in
growth that creates opportunities for
everyone
fundamentally it is built on a belief in
strong and Lasting Democratic
institutions like the one we are in
today
so without further delay I am pleased
and honored to welcome president
Funderland for her joint address to
Parliament
thank you
prime minister Dear Justin
Mr Speaker of the Senate Mr Speaker of
the House
excellencies senators
members of the House of Commons
distinguished guests
people of Canada
thank you very much for welcoming me to
the heart of Canada the home of Canadian
democracy
they say
Hard Times reveal true friends
and this is what the European Union in
Canada are
true friends
the history of our democracies is tied
together
so many Canadians have their family
roots in Europe
many of your parents and grandparents
have fought in Europe
during two world wars
they were sent to far away places on the
other side of the ocean
tens of thousands of them lost their
lives
in the trenches of Belgium
In the Heat of Sicily
on the beaches of Normandy on D-Day
I am a European of German nationality
it was German Nazism and fascism
that brought death and destruction upon
Europe and the world
but it were Allied Forces
that brought Liberty back to all of us
the United democracies freed us from
dictatorship
thus we owe our democracy also
to you
the people of Canada
and we will be forever grateful
for the sacrifice
your parents and grandparents made
and for the invaluable gift of freedom
thank you
today almost 80 years after the end of
World War II
the values of freedom and democracy
are still a strong bridge between the
two shores of the Atlantic
you
the people of Canada
have built this country
as a community that is open to all
Beyond ethnicity
language
or religion
a true community of values
and it is the same spirit that brings us
Europeans together
27 proud countries
24 official languages
in one Union almost half a billion
people
the European Union
today we are a community of values and
together we are
a community of Destiny
the more painful it is
that the very values that unite us
are challenged today like never before
one year ago
Russia sent tanks drones
and missiles
over the borders and against a sovereign
and peaceful country
since then countless lives have been
shattered
countless families separated
hundreds of thousands of young
ukrainians had to kiss their loved ones
goodbye
and left to the front
to fight for freedom
Millions more had to leave not only
their homes
but also their dreams behind
all of this
because President Putin refuses
to recognize
their freedom
and their independence
and this we can simply not accept
thank you
we will never accept that the military
power with fantasies of Empire
roll the tanks across an international
border
we will never accept
that Putin denies the very existence of
Ukraine as a state
and as a nation
we will never accept this threat to
European security
and to the very Foundation
of our International Community
and I know that Canada's commitment is
just as adamant as ours
Canada and the European Union will
uphold the U.N Charter
we will stand up for Ukraine to be the
master of their own future nothing about
Ukraine without Ukraine and we will keep
supporting Ukraine for as long as it
takes
thank you
Canada has a very special connection to
Ukraine
many proud Canadians are also very proud
of their Ukrainian Heritage
and you understood the gravity of events
in Ukraine before many others
including many Europeans
in 2014 Putin invaded Ukraine for the
first time
already back then
Canada decided
to set up a training mission for the
Ukrainian military
operation unifier has trained over 35
000 Ukrainian soldiers
and this has proven to be vital in the
hours that followed the full-scale
Russian invasion of last year
Putin believed that he would get Keith
within three days
what a strategic mistake
Ukraine's resistance has stunned the
world
that was primarily of course because of
the courage of the Ukrainian people
but it was also and crucially
because of the professionalism
of the Ukrainian soldiers many trained
by Canada
and I cannot overstate this
Canada has saved Ukraine's in the first
days
thank you
and I want to thank everyone involved in
operation unifier for your amazing
service
Canada's response to the war in Ukraine
has gone above and beyond the Call of
Duty
and I'm so grateful Dear Justin
for your constant close cooperation
during this year
everything we did for Ukraine
we did it together
because we believe that Ukraine and the
values that it strives for must Prevail
in this world
first we believe that Ukraine deserves
our steadfast military and economic
support
the support package
that Europe has put together with almost
100 billion Canadian dollars
is unprecedented in living memory
Canada is also contributing well beyond
your fair share
and now European military trainers are
working side by side with Canadian
trainers
second we believe that Russia must pay
for its crime of aggression
our sanctions have been closely aligned
since day one of the invasion
and now because of our common price on
price cap on oil
Russian proceeds from crude oil and
petroleum products have plunged by 48 in
February from a year ago
and third
we believe that ukrainians must be the
masters of their own future
they have a right to chose their
Association
and Ukraine has made its choice
they want to be member of the European
Union
but Putin wants to force Ukraine to be
part of Russia
he has achieved exactly opposite
today Ukraine is candidate country to
join the European Union
and Europe is leading the effort to help
Ukraine rebuild their country
and Canada
is a key partner for this focusing not
only on infrastructure
but also on healing the physical and
mental wounds of Ukrainian victims
and we cannot ease their pain and
suffering
but we can ease their healing and I
thank you for that
this is what it means
that Europe and Canada are like-minded
partners
we share the same purpose
the same belief
and this is true not only for our
governments
but also for our people
think about the way Canadians and
Europeans welcomed Ukraine refugees
when Ukrainian refugees knocked on our
door
Europeans and Canadians did not hesitate
for one moment
and today
4 million ukrainians live and work
inside our Union
the people of Europe have opened their
hearts and their homes and the same is
true
for the people of Canada
you are now hosting more than 165
000 ukrainians an incredible amount for
a country on the other side of the ocean
but beyond the numbers
are the stories
your stories
stories of heart-wrenching separation
stories of dangerous flight to safety
stories of finally a warm embrace here
in Canada
and I know that some of you are with us
today in the gallery so please join me
in honoring all of them all the
Canadians who make this country a
country of solidarity and Hope
miss you
foreign
person
age
places
[Music]
energetic
already
MR2
news
[Music]
Surplus
is
crucial
foreign
photographic
nursery song
premiere
the Canada
is
expert
the Como
foreign
[Applause]
after the two World Wars
the world declared that all human beings
are entitled to equal
and inalienable rights
but today some powers are explicitly
trying to destroy this basic principle
I was in butcher
right after its Liberation by Ukraine's
Army
I saw the body backs lined up by the
side of the street
I heard the stories
of rape
of executions in Cold Blood
carried out by Russian troops
and Russia continues to commit
atrocities
bombing civilians striking the most
vulnerable
the United Nations says Russia is using
rape
and sexual violence as part of its
military strategy in Ukraine
this is not only a war in Ukraine it is
also warned human rights and it is a war
on women's rights
but Ukrainian women are fighting back
they have been fighting back ever since
2014.
when the first Invasion Russian invasion
happened
women were not allowed
to carry out combat duties
but they did not care and they started
joining the Army
let me quote Lieutenant Colonel Melanie
Lake
of the Canadian Armed Forces who led
operation unifier
and she is with us today somewhere
she said
and I quote
Ukrainian women did not wait for doors
to be open for them to serve in all
capacities
they broke the doors down end of quote
these women also smashed a glass ceiling
right over the head of the Russian
Invaders
since the start of the war the number of
women serving in the military has more
than doubled
and it's not sure not just about women
in the army
millions of Ukrainian women are standing
up for their children's future in
Freedom
one Ukrainian woman above all has become
a global symbol
the first lady of Ukraine olena zelenska
she stayed in Kiev in the darkest hours
together with her husband
she's emblematic
of the courage of the Ukrainian people
I saw her in action on the global stage
as an advocate for her people especially
those most vulnerable
an unbreakable Force for good
these women aren't inspiration for all
of us and I want to honor them on the
Eve on the of the international women's
day
thank you
at war or in peace we need all our
talents to live up to the big challenges
of our time
Canada knows this well
eight years ago when asked why he
appointed a gender equal cabinet
prime minister Trudeau replied
because it's 2015 as simple as that
and I am proud to lead the first gender
balanced College in the history of the
European Commission
and before the end of my mandate 50 of
all managers of the European commission
will be women
[Applause]
bring different perspectives diversity
leads to better decisions better
societies
gender equality does not just happen
not even because it's 2023.
it requires day-to-day attention and
commitment
that women and go
and go from violence
to ensure that women earn the same as
their male colleagues because they
deserve it
to ensure that women as well as men can
have a career and a family
to ensure that women can reach the very
top level because they are qualified
we have a duty
to set an example to society and the
economy of what a world of fair chances
looks like and this Duty counts every
day not just on International women's
day
my dear friends in this August House
no democracy is perfect
but all democracies are perfectable
this is our mission
and this is what brings us together
it is the mission
that has moved generation upon
generation of great Canadians and
Europeans
they had the audacity
to look Beyond
the imperfection of what is
and to see the beauty
of what could be
the generation that brought Europe
together after two world wars and after
the fall of the Soviet Union
and they're Generations that made Canada
the inclusive and welcoming country it
is today
a country that is proud of its Heritage
and open to the Future
the home of indigenous people as well as
newcomers
a place of traditions
and innovation
where it does not matter who you are how
you pray and who you love
Canada where you can make the most of
your life and the best of your community
and this is also my vision of Europe
this is what I work for every single day
so
Canada
and Europe let us walk this path
together thank you very much
thank you
may I see Madame La Presidente